that is a curious question
how does creativity begin in darkness
i don't know i mean like you know i
could be
dreaming or i could be driving um or i
could be in the middle of a phone call
and something will just pop into my head
that that that to me is where
my uh my thoughts go when you talk about
creativity coming out of darkness
because usually like that kind of stuff
is like spontaneous
and
really not related to what's happening
around me sometimes like i feel like
it's like a daydream effect of like oh
that's interesting
maybe i should maybe i should do
something about that or write something
about it or whatever you know
um and i can't really describe where
that comes from or why it happens when
it does
you know writer's block is a thing i
guess um
you know where it's like no new ideas
maybe it's just because you're
being paid to come up with ideas that
that it can get difficult whereas in
if it's um
like for me i'm
like constantly writing
but i've never been paid
to be a writer
at least yet so
i feel like the demand of creatively for
you to be constantly on if that's your
profession
as a writer is way more
difficult probably and stressful
to be constantly on an editor or a
director is like you you know yeah you
might have an off day but you're still
making things happen in a tangible way
in front of you like where the footage
is exists
in the computer that you have to find
your way through
but as a writer
i think um
you know that could be really
challenging but for me those things tend
to happen in the middle of while i'm
doing something else
uh like i'm i'm in the middle of editing
a scene and then i've thought about
something completely random that i want
to
make a point to um to write down because
i don't know where that's going to be
value it might be valuable in the
project but or the next project or you
know because all those
ideas um i think influence the work that
i'm
either
about to do or currently doing as well
so to
to figure out where it all comes from
though
i don't know i mean can you be taught to
be creative
yes
but there's also a
a i think
something like born like you're born
with this or people are born with a
exceptional um
you know i don't i i don't think i'm
uh like the stephen hawking of of like
you know in in a sense of of or like
this spielberger
you know i'm just trying to make my way
uh to try to create stories and tell
them but i think that there's some
natural talent that i was just gifted
with that and again
was cultivated at a young age for me and
that really i think has helped
contribute to where i am now and
hopefully where i continue to go
but um but where it came from i mean is
anybody's guess i i think that when you
see somebody's
working like
inspired like it changes you like for me
um
like you know that's
that's just why i think that's why we
have
those reactions because it's like where
did that even come from how did they
even create that or think of that or do
it that way or you know even making all
those collaborations happen every single
person and
uh in in like i mean i hate to use lord
of the rings but it's like when i saw
that film i'm like yeah the set design
the music the directing the actors
everybody just this magic moment
happened and i mean that means that that
creativity existed and all of them
individually first before it came to
that moment too so i just think it's all
fascinating i have no idea how it
happens sometimes it's just
the universe to me
is that the film that impacted you the
most lord of the rings
i i would say it's definitely up there
for sure yeah
not gattica
not gattica in the same sense no i think
laura lorraine is the one that that
really
um
gattica is a movie that that that
intellectually stimulates me in in uh in
other ways maybe just because of when i
first saw it but lord of the rings is
um
something i'd never seen before and and
so that was i think why it showed me the
magic of filmmaking in a in
in like the biggest and boldest way
possible
what is day one of your writing process
like
um
usually i
am jotting down
random ideas on just a document
and eventually like sort of like
highlights of a structure to some extent
like whatever i can come up with um but
then
i don't know i mean it changes uh
depending on what i'm what i'm
working on
and i think again every script is like
slightly different
too um
collaborating and writing with a writing
partner is like my preferred way of
working as a writer um
just because again
i think that having somebody to bounce
ideas off of
critique tell you that that idea is
but this one but that made me think of
this one which maybe is better
and then you're like no that's but
now we're getting somewhere you know
what i mean like that part of that
process is
is really fun for me
i know a lot of people prefer to write
alone
um
and yeah i don't know it's got to be
like an organic process at least for me
right now i'm still kind of early on in
my
my writing career i guess because um
i've only really written this
projects that i've made which um
which is sort of at a necessity to some
extent
but i don't think i'll always do it that
way i might be the guy that gives you an
idea as a writer um
i might write it myself
or collaborate or you know co-write it
i'm not really that um
needy i guess in that part of the
process i just
the the script is a blueprint for the
movie so i think as a director i'll
always be involved but
um or i'd like to think i will always be
involved but maybe i'll find the right
script immediately and then just like
let's go you know i don't know
it's a long way ended up a long way
around saying
i don't um i mean it just starts with
jotting down ideas but that's
as a writer it's like that but even as a
you know director of shot shooting like
plans and all that stuff it all starts
it's got to start on paper for me
writing things down is how i remember
for me um
you know like note taking and all that
stuff it all it all comes back around
for me like it will stay in my brain if
i write it that's basically what i'm
saying
so i might not think about it for four
years but it's still probably in there
somewhere
i hope
what is day seven of your writing
process like
well hopefully i've gotten somewhere by
that point
but i still think that like the half the
battle is figuring out
kind of
what this
i mean you know your structure but you
know what the story is that you're
trying to tell
um it's you know i hope maybe the ending
i don't know i mean like writing a
script it can take me like
you know three years to get to the end
it can take me six months it just
depends
for i am the bluebird how long did it
take you to finish the script
oh well
i'm the bluebird i was in film school at
the time so
i think it took as long as i had in the
class to get into production i think it
was like
three months and that movie um
was
you know not ready to be shot um
like for sure but that's something that
i've experienced um in particular in the
editing and again where i think why i
think editing has been the path that
i've followed since then um out of
necessity but also
just because that part of the process is
where the movie got crafted and also
we
released that film
as implanted in 2012.
so um i am the bluebird was the original
title
and was also i think 20 minutes longer
at that point too
um
and so all of that was
i guess
the long-winded version of saying
yeah i shot it i think i spent maybe
four months on the script but that was
i would i think it was never ready to
really be shot and i learned that the
hard way and so i would
maybe just say
that i can oh at least i'll say i'll
never do that again uh if i if i can
help it i don't want to go into
a production on something that where the
script isn't ready
unless of course it's a documentary
where you don't have one which i just
did and that was also very different and
interesting too but
um but you have a three-act structure
with a documentary in some ways yes you
do you definitely have a structure
and
but again you're create you're writing
it as an editor though in that case
which um
you know you're you have oh i mean you
can you know we have a lot of archive in
zero gravity and there's other ways to
kind of enhance that storyline but but
in general it was the story unfolding in
front of you
is what the movie is and you only have
so much control over that um whereas and
if it's a script you can obviously
rewrite a scene and do a hundred
different ways
to to get there so like with implanted
it was
uh not ready to be shot with zero
gravity it was there's no like we had to
start shooting it to make the movie you
know so it's very two sides of the same
coin but the end result was um
you know is the story going to be
compelling
and um
you know of course you're not going to
go on that journey unless you think it
think it is but you learn a lot along
the way for no matter what the project
is